Bernie Sanders has absolutely destroyed third
quarter campaign fundraising, the third quarter.
It ended at the end of September and it ended
as the Bernie Sanders most successful fundraising
period of his entire 2020 campaign.
So let's back up.
As you probably know or would suspect, I hate
how politics is funded here in the United
States, the system is broken.
Uh, the game is broken.
It's a corrupt game.
It has, it's a game with rules that don't
make any sense.
Fundraising super PACS, dark money, citizens
United money is speech.
I mean, it's really horrifying what is going
on, but right now this is the system that
we have.
And the way you win elections is by raising
a whole bunch of money so it still matters
and it can be assigned in the system that
we have of enthusiasm for candidates.
Uh, it's, it can be a sort of proxy indicators,
so to speak.
And Bernie Sanders raised $25 million in the
third quarter of this year.
So in terms of polling, Bernie Sanders has
not had a good third quarter.
The momentum has been behind Elizabeth Warren
in the polling, as I've said, a much to the
disgust of many people in my audience.
But I will always tell it to you like it is
a, but that's polling in fundraising.
Bernie Sanders is more than excelling now,
reporting more than 1 million individual donors
to his campaign.
That's a metric he achieved faster than any
democratic presidential candidate ever.
And there's some very interesting data that's
been released by the Sanders campaign.
The most common profession among Bernie's
donors is teachers.
The most common employers among Bernie's donors
are Walmart, Amazon, and Starbucks, which
I mean, what you have to understand is there
some of the largest employers in the country.
So I wouldn't be surprised if more than one
candidate can tout lots of donors from Walmart,
Amazon, and Starbucks, but still interesting
nonetheless.
So we now have an interesting situation with
the fourth, uh, democratic presidential debate
coming up in just over two weeks, actually
two weeks to the day.
We now have an interesting situation with
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren.
Um, there's the Joe Biden question as the
centrist establishment candidate.
And then there is the Bernie Warren.
We are the most progressive candidates who
have a shot at this thing, sort of a, a status
quo that we're dealing with.
On the one hand, Bernie's fundraising is absolutely
unmatched.
The numbers.
Tell us this.
On the other hand, Elizabeth Warren continues
to build momentum in the polls, so what could
potentially cause things to break one way
or the other?
One thing we do need to talk about is media
coverage.
I just saw a report, although I did not fact
check it, but it alleges that ABC news devoted
only seven minutes so far period in all of
their evening newscasts to Bernie Sanders
campaign, which seems absolutely and totally
bonkers.
This is not, again, this is not me shilling
for one key one candidate or the other.
It's just pointing out that given the level
of support Bernie does have, which has been
sort of going back and forth between being
in second and third place, seven minutes of
coverage seems quite low.
We should fact check that.
So media coverage is going to be a big thing.
Another one is debates, but the, the caveat
about debates is that debates don't seem to
have had the effect on Bernie's polling that,
uh, maybe we would have imagined Bernie Sanders.
I was looking back at the polling today.
I've not identified any significant or notable
jumps that Bernie Sanders had.
Uh, after debates we've seen drops for Joe
PiDon.
It seems that the debates have not been particularly
good for Joe Biden.
Uh, Elizabeth Warren has been steadily gaining
since the start of the debates.
And even before that, most everybody else
has been relatively unaffected.
There's, you know, one Emerson poll that has
Andrew Yang at 8%, uh, whether we can trust
that one poll with that high number and whether
it's related to the debates.
These are open questions, but for Bernie,
it does not seem to have done much one way
or the other.
So we'll see what happens as far as the debates
go, it's terrible.
To go back to the real core of the issue here,
it's terrible that the name of the game is
raising money.
It's terrible that this is how politics is
done.
It's terrible that congressional terms are
two years.
And when you combine that with the system
of fundraising that we have, as soon as you're
elected, you have four to five months and
then you've got to start raising money in
campaigning for your reelection.
If you plan to do that.
So it's a terrible game that has to be played
for as long as it is the game that is being
played.
You want to see the more progressive candidates
raise the most money and Bernie Sanders has
raised a ton of it in the third quarter of
2019 we'll continue to follow fundraising
numbers.